when i talk with developers using cloud  run they often tell me that i love not  having to pay for idle capacity  for example if you have less traffic  outside business hours you pay less  but many systems have an hourly base  load this could be because your users  are spread out enough that there are  always requests reaching your cloud run  service  you can now get a 17 discount on this  base load if you commit to use cloud run  for a year  in this case you might commit to one  dollar per hour with a discount this  means that your one dollar worth of  cloud run usage per hour will only be  charged 83 cents  this discount applies across all your  cloud run services in a region in all  projects connected with your billing  account  you'll pay the normal rate for traffic  above your commitment just like before  click commitments in your billing  account to play with the numbers and see  how much you could save